all right everybody it is time for
drew's news when life flattens your
tires we'll pump them back up with that
good news air
well with me at the desk is my dearest
friend who i know could always change
any tire it's ross matthew no like call
a different friend
i know i couldn't do that like do you
keep a jack in your car i don't even
know if i keep a jack in my siri what's
a jack i don't know my dad was a
mechanic and you would have thought that
he would have taught me how to change a
tire and maybe he tried but i was not
interested
[Applause]
well here's a fun story a really fun one
there's a brand new job opening up at
buckingham palace and drew barrymore i
feel like you might need to apply for
this one apartment therapy reports the
queen is hiring a decorator she wants to
redecorate the entire royal household
room by room so she's she's looking for
someone with a passion for historic
buildings check good communication
skills check check and a natural team
player check check check uh the job pays
forty thousand dollars a year it has
full benefits and a pension
and you get 33 days off a year
all right
so madam is this a job you'd want and
what would you do with it i love
designing you've got a great aesthetic i
want to get her one of those neon signs
above her bed that just says yes queen
i got it figured out i love that
but who would not want to work as a
designer you're
me out there making people's spaces
brighter and happier places for them to
be
queen or no queen i'm in yeah i think so
too and i think it's time for the whole
royal family they need a little refresh
on everything right so let's start with
a little decor
well this is um a story i found and i
thought oh i have to bring this to the
desk okay so attention new yorkers we
are officially the first city where this
is happening
uber is joining forces with
yellow cabs the new york times reports
that starting this spring uber will
allow you to order a yellow taxi on
their app they're teaming up with the
two apps that already exist for yellow
cab curb and cmt and if you order a
yellow cab on uber you'll pay uber rates
including surge prices
what do you think well i think we have
to they have to make this kind of change
because it's a brand new world i just
have to say as somebody with a proud
4.89 uber rating i hope that this
doesn't affect it because i'm really
proud of that i do have to say i am
4.89
is good
i don't know what my uber rating is i i
know that i'm a happy passenger yeah but
i feel like i'm also a late to get
downstairs passengers oh that's gonna
affect your score
4.89 that means i'm polite i'm crazy i
talk but i don't over talk
do you choose the
like talk to me or don't talk to me
button i let them figure it out you know
what i mean you you say yes i i allow
conversation express yourself through
uber okay how many hands show raise of
hands say no to conversation on your
uber app right there proud i love it i'm
i'm sorry aren't you glad you raised
your hand now
okay why do you why do you do it i talk
about this all the time to my co-workers
because i work overnight shifts and i
just feel like that's
a no conversation like it's acceptable
it should be acceptable yeah yes to me
and you like that option i love that
i like your approach
[Music]
you